des badauds il s'appelle alexander
dolgopolov et social n'a que 25 ans et
il est une étoile montante de l'humour
en russie ses blagues sont crus certains
diront de mauvais cet extrait il se
moque vulgairement de gilles hui de la
vierge marie
dolgopolov devait donner un spectacle
hier dans un bar de moscou mais il a
annulé à la dernière minute quand il a
appris que deux policiers en civil
l'attendait à la porte et anna paule je
ne sais pas ce qui se passe mais je ne
suis pas surpris a expliqué l'humoriste
sur une vidéo
nous l'avons joint quelques heures plus
tard j'ai décidé de quitter la russie
parce que j'ai vraiment peur dit-il peur
d'aller en prison car ces fréquences la
police locale se penchent bel et bien
sur son cas dans cette lettre envoyée au
propriétaire d'une salle de spectacles
de saint pétersbourg où il est monté sur
scène il ya un an
la police exige des informations
précises sur le jeune humoriste et le
contenu sont numéro qui depuis a été vu
par plus de 3 millions d'internautes
ils se moquent non seulement de la
religion et du président poutine et ce
qui selon lui le vénère aveuglément
et elle dépasse moindre aide est acquis
au projet moa qu'aqua cash money devions
nous avons son avocat a dit que la
police refuse de lui donner des détails
mais confirme qu'elle agit sur la base
d'une plainte déposée par un citoyen
pour insulte à la foi des croyants un
crime passible de trois ans de prison en
russie un pays ou insulter les autorités
sur internet peut en coûter tout autant
cette loi est un outil de répression
contre les jeunes dit dolgopolov et
c'est dans un climat de peur constante
que nous travaillons nicolas est lui
aussi humoriste il doute que son
collègue soit véritablement en danger me
comprends qu'ils soient terrorisé la
lumière de ce qui s'est passé l'été
dernier avec l'incarcération de jeunes
manifestants certains pour des animaux
et c'est une nouvelle étape que vient de
franchir la police en s'acharnant sur un
simple l'humoriste dit son avocat qui
représentait d'ailleurs un des étudiants
arrêtés en juillet vous croyez
sincèrement qu'il risque la prison
progetto d'or lui dit il est seulement
et c'est une façon d'envoyer un signal à
tous les autres humoristes qui se moque
de l'église mais qu'aucune accusation
n'ait été déposée contre lui
dolgopolov refuse de rentrer au pays
tant et aussi longtemps qu'il n'aura pas
la garantie qu'il pourra travailler en
toute liberté et sittard alter escaut
radio-canada moscou